sur la Star Academy Anisha la grande
gagnante de cette dernière saison elle a
fait réagir sur les réseaux sociaux sur
les RS
cette fois-ci c'est son look qui a
suscité l'intérêt les internautes
maquillage talon la jeune femme apparaît
métamorphosée et ça ça fait énormément
réagir
compensez-vous pensez-vous que
ça le fait franchement qu'en pensez-vous
aujourd'hui
montrez la photo s'il vous plaît qui m'a
non mais la photo s'il vous plaît merci
donc elle est sur un canapé c'est un
château d'axe vous pouvez le voir voilà
donc là c'est vrai que là moi là ça m'a
voilà ça va ça m'a pris au corps tu es
choqué extrêmement choqué
je suis elle a quel âge
pourquoi tu es choqué toi je suis très
perturbé quoi c'est quoi qui te choque
c'est le le parquet flottant c'est
qu'ils sont en train de la dénaturer de
lui enlever
ils sont en train de lui enlever son
naturel ils sont en train de fabriquer
une Jennifer ou une chanteuse
Jennifer à la carrière exceptionnelle
oui mais c’est pas
ils sont en train de la casser en lui
demandant de se relooker de se renier
casser c'est Nolwenn
j'avais demandé si je pouvais prendre la
parole sur ce sujet et je vous remercie
de me l'avoir donné
oui je suis choqué j'ai le droit d'être
choqué Cyril je vous rappelle je vous ai
filé 200 boules pour le Sénégal
c'est toi qui a voulu parler oui Kelly
et moi je suis d'accord avec Gilles à un
moment donné où la nana elle a été élue
par toutes les personnes qui l'aimaient
comme elle l'était donc elle était là
elle était un peu timide elle avait son
petit look à elle elle était très
mignonne elle était toute douce elle
était toute chou et là on est en train
de lui mettre des trucs à cuire des
talons aiguilles qu'elle aurait jamais
mis de sa vie
je suis désolé la pause elle est lassive
ça lui ressemble pas donc lui je me
demande si on lui a pas demandé de
prendre cette pause moi je trouve que ça
lui ressemble pas c'est pas elle et je
comprends que les femmes qui ont voté
pour elle bah soit pas content de voir
cette transformation si elle avait
grandi dans le temps je peux comprendre
qu'elle change parce qu'elle prend la
maturité généralement deux semaines on
prend pas énormément donc vous avez déjà
changé tu as vu la pause
je peux vous dire vraiment ce que j'en
pense moi les chevaux
mais
j'aime bien avoir la vie des autres dès
que ça tu jettes fondateur
ah oui
si la féminité est imposée elle est
briefée si elle a eu un brainstorming
avant en disant oui tu sais on a fait
des études comme ça de marketing il va
falloir que tu sois plus comme ceci ou
plus comme cela là je trouve qu'il y a
un malaise effectivement parce qu'elle
ne correspond pas à ce pourquoi on a on
a décidé de voter pour elle sinon moi ça
me choque pas qu'à se mettre des
cuissardes
moi je lui souhaite la la carrière et la
longévité de Jenifer
elle a évolué
une chasse à nichard également que
Céline Dion
la vérité c'est qui a dit qu'on est gris
sur les réseaux sur Instagram qu'on
Twitter et voilà vous en faites un petit
buzz et comme alors je vais vous dire ce
qui se passe maintenant c'est le nouvel
c'est le nouveau truc maintenant c'est à
dire que tu as
ou qui vont mettre un truc sur Instagram
et tu as les plus gros que mal encore
certains une putaclic qui vont se dire
tiens on va faire un sujet ah ouais les
internautes choqués par la tenue
Jean-Charles Billy voilà Monique et
Delphine et les gars et derrière ça fait
genre ils te font un truc de fou et te
mettre un titre énorme dans ce non mais
là c'est exactement la toile est en feu
voilà donc je vais vous dire il y a rien
qui est en feu du tout donc arrêtez
c'est encore c'est voilà c'est parce que
en ce moment on a un gros problème avec
les journalistes il y a journaliste et
journaliste voilà et le problème c'est
que voilà en ce moment et ben ça peut ce
qu'il écrive comme ils veulent sauver
leur peau ils veulent sauver leur voilà
leur sortie de presse ils écrivent tout
et n'importe quoi pour faire du CLIC et
pour faire gagner de l'argent pour
gagner de l'argent donc forcément ils
écrivent tout et n'importe quoi
je ne voulais pas le dire mais je ne
crois pas
je voulais pas dire mais je le pense